flowing contours bereft of on slightly
corners and edges a streamlined design
that looks futuristic today but this car
is a cousin of the original Volkswagen
bug the man who created it was Ferdinand
Porsche and the car was a design
precursor to the production model that
would make his name world-famous the
porsche 64 was a very limited edition
with just three built the aerodynamic
form helped boost its top speed to 160
km/h 20 km/h 19
he wanted to build racing cars and
products for the people folks not a foot
off the bone
the porsche 64 was created in 1939 in
parallel with the original Volkswagen
the Beetle Ferdinand Porsche was head of
VW at the time
the 64 was supposed to compete in a
high-profile Berlin to Rome race the
race was canceled due to the outbreak of
World War 2 a porsche 64 would have been
among the favourites the aerodynamics
and lightweight construction were ahead
of their time the 64 is housed in a
museum located in Hamburg's redeveloped
- city docks area the unique collection
on display focuses on post-war German
racing car heritage and therefore
Porsche it was a personal mission for
Thomas Kearney and Oliver Schmidt
when Thomas like the two friends had
always been fascinated by Porsche models
that interest evolved over the years and
eventually they said there's more to
German post-war Motorsports
than just Porsche it was the post-war
reconstruction era that really
interested them a time when car makers
had very modest means at their disposal
in Midland hot auto centerin isn't one
of those pioneers was ultimate a a
racing driver from Austria he built and
drove this curious looking contraption
after his death in 1995 the museum
bought that Porsche Volkswagen mongrel
as well as MOT a spare parts collection
thomas kernig had no idea of the
treasure trove he'd accidentally
acquired
it was while rummaging around in old
boxes belonging to Monty the Thomas
kerning discovered parts from the second
64 model and now takes pride of place in
the museum
as well the biggest problem was the
missing body he recalls they took the
model they already had as a template but
each model was experimental so there
were a lot of differences in thoughts
like it does feel until she the diet is
the incident thoughts like a fictitious
restoring that second 64 to its former
glory took the best part of a decade but
you won't find this beauty gracing the
streets in terms of automotive
historical value its inestimable the
four-cylinder boxer engine with a
displacement just short of one liter was
a product of Volkswagen the air-cooled
engine with two carburetors generated
about 35 horsepower
design mother
this unique aerodynamic body was
designed by Aaron commendeth the man
behind the design of the Volkswagen as
well as the record-breaking Mercedes T
80 later on all these projects were
overseen by Ferdinand Porsche the
specifications book from back then
must have included elements of the
Volkswagen a lamented this folks logs
because affinity you could recognize the
form of the beetle in their ribbing here
in the hood at the front and then at the
rear we find these air inlets that
weren't featured in the beetle to those
in the know will recognize what you
could call a squashed beetle and i'm
gong swapnika token kpop and the basis
for later rear engine Porsche models the
356 and the 911
the interior is pure Porsche sober or
even Spartan the awesome 64 the first
racing car ever to bear the famous
Porsche name
you